now i'm choosing to uh i'm choosing to
end the term
on this question because i really like
this question now i don't know about you
as a student that's weird to me the
concept of liking a question so let me
try and explain why i like this question
number one uh it draws together quite a
few different ideas in maths that you've
been building for a long time so it's
not like
exercises you know which are very simple
and repetitive and like just this one
one skill let's do it over and over and
over again i find that very boring
this it draws together a whole bunch of
um
abilities and um techniques and
algorithms you've learned okay so
there's the first thing
the second thing i like about it is that
it justifies the trapezoidal rule you
learn trapezoidal you learn simpsons and
you're like
why do we do this you can use
integration from
you know so many different functions
that it's precise why would you go
through this
awkward long formula which is inaccurate
anyway okay
this will show you one of the reasons
why and thirdly
um it sort of solves a mystery for me
which i had when i was younger
um they often talk about okay we know
what pi
is and we know it to some certain number
of
decimal places right okay now they used
to say or they still say
you know we have calculated pi to
you know however however many decimal
places and i think
it's something like um 10 to the 14 or
10 of the 15
decimal places that we've worked out
which is crazy like why would you ever
need so many
that's beside the point my question was
how how
how did they do it like what is pi no
seriously by definition what is pi
it's a ratio between
between the the circumference of a
circle
and its diameter right if there's about
3.14
diameters around the circumference right
now if that's your definition of pie
how do you get pi to any degree of
accuracy
right if it's about a ratio like what
did they do get a really really big
circle
and a really long piece of string and
then just write it around like how did
they work that out
how do they get it to such a stupid
level of accuracy
when you finish solving this question it
starts to prod at how they do that which
is really
quite clever when you think about it it
has less to do with circles
almost nothing to do with circles
actually so let's have a go
part a it starts off very simply show
that the tangent at
p has a given equation so
you might not have done this question
before or yet rather but we can work
through this
right the graph is cos okay if we want
the tangent of p
what am i going to need to do
first i need to differentiate so if
y is equal to cos x the derivative of
course is
it's the last day of school wow brain's
not on yet it's like come on give me a
break i even turned up to school you
should be happy that i'm here
the derivative is negative sign okay
now we watch it at this particular point
and they tell you it lines up with pi of
four
okay so you'd say when x is pi
and four y is going to be equal to cos
pi over 4 which is
102. you really are slow today
and um the derivative which is negative
sine of pi over 4
is negative
okay great what do i do with that where
do i put it
point graded form which looks like this
okay so let's just quickly chuck a bit
what am i going to get 1 on
root 2 minus 1 on root 2
x minus pi on 4. now
excuse me that is the equation of the
tangent they just want it in a specific
awkward form which is neither slow
gradient form nor general form but
whatever okay we can multiply through by
root two
okay so that gives you root two y minus
one
i'm going to get rid of the brackets as
well so that gives you minus x
plus pi over okay
and then all they want to do is swap the
negative things around so you get x
plus that is that
plus pi over four as required
okay then they say show the m
that's this coordinate up here which is
on the tangent
that lines up with pi on six okay show
that
m has a y coordinate of and then they
give you one
and then they ask you to find the
corresponding y coordinate for m
right so how would i do it this is part
of this
part all you have to do is take that
equation you just got
stick in part three and stick in pound
six
okay and you get there now let's just
quickly jot down because um
for m the y coordinate and m
they do actually give that to you and um
i think you guys can work that out
yourself
okay now when you're working at the y
coordinate for n
when you stick it in the only difference
is you get a negative here
okay so you'll get 1 over 24 root 2
12 minus pi and there's your coordinates
okay
now part c is where it starts to get
interesting and this is why i was
talking about trapezoidal rule
okay they asked you to work out the
areas of two
trapeziums okay the first one
is i think it's m c
d m okay in other words it's that
trapezium built off of the tangent
okay but then they will ask you to work
out another trapezium which is not
labeled on the diagram
okay partly because it's quite hard to
label on the diagram but if you draw it
in
try and do it carefully
something like that okay so it's abdc
okay you can see it's a trapezium not
just above like the tangent
but just below okay so how do we work
out these um
trapezius uh you already worked out
these lengths here
right so that refers to cm
cm there
okay and this refers to dn okay so these
are two
parallel sides here okay so if i want to
work out the area
of let's do this bigger trapezium okay
um
so i should have written c m n
d okay what's the formula for the error
trapezium again
h on two and then the parallel sides
right what is the height here it's here
isn't it
that's the height pi on 3 minus pi on 6
is pi on 6. so that's going to become pi
on 12 half the front there because i'm
dividing by 2.
and then you've got these two things now
it looks like it's awful but there are
conjugates aren't there
they're conjugates so when i subtract so
when i add
this and this the pies are going to
cancel
aren't they can you see that when you
add them together so instead i'm just
going to get two of these guys
okay 2 times 1 over 24
root 2 times 12.
okay now that's convenient look at that
2
12 that's 24 you're dividing by 24 so
you're just getting
pi on 12 times root 2.
is that okay see where i got that from
see how these are
these pies will cancel out because
they're conjugates
that's the bigger trapezium the upper
one that's built off the tangent what's
the area
of the smaller one um this is uh abdc
isn't it
well it's going to be the same height
right the trapeziums the trapezium they
line up like that so this is still going
to be pi on 12
out the front okay now what's our a and
b what are the lengths of our parallel
sides here
well this one will be cos pi over three
and this one will be cos pi over six
what's cos power six that's root three
and two isn't it
and cos pi over three that's a half
yep so i can just tidy that up a little
bit
pi on 24 root three plus one let's check
if that's what i got before
always reassure you get the right answer
there you go okay